في رأيك، ما الذي تغير في حسابات الولايات المتحدة
بعد وفاة هؤلاء
الأفراد الثلاثة في الخدمة في
نهاية الأسبوع الماضي؟ حسنًا، لقد وصل الأمر إلى نقطة الغليان.
أعتقد أن ما تتحدث عنه يا أليكس
هو اجتماع مؤسسة الأمن القومي
معًا، كما تعلم أننا تحدثنا عن
هؤلاء الـ 160 شخصًا  الضربات التي حدثت
منذ 7 أكتوبر ولكن عندما
تتحدث عن
إثارة الخطاب الإيراني أه في المنطقة
التي نتحدث فيها عن الشرق
الأوسط بأكمله من إيران
إلى لبنان فأنت تتحدث عن تلك
الرسائل التي كانت  القيام بهذه الأنواع من
الأشياء ليس منذ 7 أكتوبر ولكن
ربما خلال العشرين عامًا الماضية أه
لم يكونوا ملحوظين، لقد
كانوا نشطين للغاية خلال الوقت الذي
كانت فيه القوات الأمريكية في العراق، لقد كانوا
نشطين للغاية منذ مغادرتنا  العراق في المنطقة
هو كما قالت بيث للتو شكل من أه
استراتيجية الأمن القومي الإيراني لوضع
هذه الإلكترونات العائمة الحرة إذا صح التعبير،
هذه القوات الخاصة في جميع أنحاء
المنطقة للقيام باستراتيجياتها الخارجية
وفي الوقت نفسه داخل إيران لديك
كامل  هناك الكثير من الخلل الوظيفي أه من
منظور وطني، لذا فهذه هي
طريقتهم في محاولة الحفاظ على
هويتهم الإقليمية والسيطرة على المنطقة وأن
يُنظر إليهم على أنهم آه أقوياء، إنه لا
يجدي نفعًا، وبالعودة إلى سؤالك
على الرغم من ما الذي تسبب في انفجار
الطاقة المفاجئ آه  أعتقد أن خطة الحملة هذه التي وضعتها
الولايات المتحدة هي لأننا كنا
نلعب لعبة الضرب مع كل
القوى الصغيرة التي تحاول
إبقائها تحت السيطرة وضربها
وعدم التعرض لأية أضرار، وقد وصل الأمر
إلى نقطة الغليان حيث يصبح الوطني
تقول المؤسسة الأمنية في الولايات المتحدة إن هذا يكفي الآن،
وعلينا أن نفعل شيئًا ما، وأعتقد أن
رد الفعل الهائل هذا الذي يربط مرة أخرى
بين إيذاء هذه القوات
وضمان عدم نشوب حرب إقليمية
هو أمر صعب للغاية ولكنه فقط
يصل إلى النقطة التي يتعين عليك فيها القيام
بشيء كهذا لوضع العدو في
الصف وأعتقد أن هذا ما يحدث
الآن